Whenever I want to learn how a movie is
put together,
one of the first things I do is get a
pen and paper and just count the shots
seriously.
It's not very technical and it's a bit
tedious,
but just tallying.
Every time there's a cut forces you to
see things in a different way.
It kills the illusion just enough that
the nuts and bolts start to come into
view.
For example,
let's take a look at pt Anderson's.
There will be blood already by the third
shot.
I noticed a camera technique that would
be used again and again throughout the
film.
This heavy emphasis on double and triple
framing in single shots.
Anderson and cinematographer Robert
Elswit.
We're clearly interested in making a
movie comprised largely of long takes,
but they keep up the momentum by
collapsing multiple shots into one
thing's never dragged on or get too
boring,
which is definitely a consideration when
your movie is two and a half hours long.
In fact,
by the end of the 14 and a half minute
dialogue,
free introduction,
I was struck by the length of the shots
and by how few there actually were 73 to
be exact and 14 and a half minutes
divided by 73 means that each shot on
average was about 12 seconds long.
That's a really long average shot length
by today's standard and something I
wasn't expecting Anderson to keep up
throughout the rest of the film.
This graph,
by the way,
showing that average shotlink have
decreased over the years,
comes from the work of Barry Salt,
who's been writing about film metrics
since the sixties and seventies,
and if you want to dive deeper into
metrics like these,
I highly recommend visiting his websites
in the metrics were all kinds of data is
listed out for literally thousands of
movies,
but I think the best insights come from
doing the counting yourself.
For example,
one of the things that occurs to you
watching there will be blood like this,
is that the value of a simple cut
increases as the number of cuts
decreases.
It's amazing how impactful a cut can be
when you're not watching them happened
at breakneck speed.
I don't mean to say that films with more
cuts are necessarily worse or better.
Just that a movie like there will be
blood finds a lot of power in a common
cinematic device.
The moment you make a decision,
it's,
it's very,
it's in stark relief to the audience and
there's.
There's a lot of a big spotlight on now
I'm changing perspective.
Now I'm telling you something else with
so few cuts his ticket,
nor says the contrast of each is dialed
up considerably and like Daniel
plainview,
Anderson and ticket or mine,
that contrast for meaning.
A lot of times it's literal cutting
between dark frames and right frames or
loud moments and quiet one.
Just a quick side note.
This sequence right here,
by the way,
shots to 50,
62,
63 are the quickest cutting in the film
by Far Anderson,
you so few shots that Dick nor had to
find ways to artificially add more cuts
to build up the momentum of this moment.
You can actually see that shots to 58 to
60 are just alternate angles of the
shots that came before them.
It's really good editing anyway.
Other times the contrast is personal.
If you want it to suggest that two
characters were different sides.
The same coin,
for example,
archrivals,
but cut from the same cloth.
All you need is two shots,
one tracking into a character,
mumbling to himself,
bathed in light,
another tracking out from a character,
mumbling to himself,
covered in shadow.
What I realized after a while is that
there's a domino effect longer takes me
more impactful cuts mean more attention
to composition,
and if you want your framing to mean
something,
then your cuts up to mean something
because the cut is where the viewer
really sees the framing and they see it
with a fresh memory,
almost an after image of the frame that
came before.
Sometimes it is actually a memory,
and if you want your cuts to mean
something,
then you have to use them sparingly and
with care.
Every single shot is filled with a kind
of anticipation because these cuts are
registered consciously.
On the viewer's mind,
we're all waiting for the next one to
come and everything around you.
Sure.
Yes,
and knows that anticipation is just a
form of focus and he's great at
channeling that heightened focus toward
the performances and when you have an
actor as magnetic as Daniel Day Lewis,
the longer the take,
the more you hang on his every word and
pause.
I see the worst in people.
I don't need to look past seeing them to
get online.
Watching this movie,
I noticed that conversations like this
or the place with the most frequent
editing on average and necessity of shot
reverse shot,
but even here,
everything is deliberate.
This sequence,
for example,
is 16 shots in three and a half minutes.
Take an hour.
Holds firm on the wide until Eli makes
the key comment.
What is it that brought you here,
sir?
Good Lord's guidance.
Of course,
developing news.
He cuts in,
but only a little while.
Daniel thinks he's still dealing with
the father.
Then when it's clear,
eli is the prime negotiator.
The scene locks on closeups as they
battled back and forth,
though,
I don't know for sure.
It looks a lot like ticking or extended
the silences here to augment the
intensity.
That's good.
It works.
Giving the shots,
breathing room on both sides of the
dialogue,
far from making the scene drag,
dials up the emotion considerably,
and this is something Henderson does
throughout the film.
Closeups are used again and again from
moments of silence,
just as much for important pieces of
dialogue.
Pt Anderson,
like the Coen brothers is great at
casting for faces and he wants us to
watch them as much as listen,
and of course he wants us to watch
Daniel plainview the most who corrodes
with bitterness across a series of
closeups even as he finds success in the
solitude that he craves.
I drink
water.
I drink it every day.
I drink the blood of flack from bandage
cracked.
There are 678 shots in there will be
blood over two and a half hours.
That means that each shot is 13 point
three seconds on average,
more than the introduction.
The movie is remarkably consistent on
this front.
Each hour or half hour taken alone will
average somewhere around 12 to 14
seconds.
Maybe this is what gives the movie,
it's steady,
but unrelenting pace,
the feeling that you're watching a
train,
you can't stop.
There are tons of ways to deconstruct a
movie,
but it's amazing what you can learn just
from looking at the shots one by one as
they go by.
For many of us,
loving a film means wanting to know how
it works with the spirit of an engineer.
We take it apart,
twist it,
turn it,
bend it,
and put it back together.
Or at least we try to.
A great movie will never give up all at
secrets,
but it will give up.
Some of this episode is brought to you
by the great courses plus the great
courses plus is an on demand video
learning service,
which basically means it's got around
7,000
online video lecture series from some
great professors about all kinds of
subjects.
Math,
history,
archeology,
art,
you name it.
One that I think you should really check
out is called the inexplicable universe
unsolved mysteries by Neil de Grasse
Tyson,
which is super heady and interesting,
and it's taught by Neil Tyson,
which is all you should need to know.
If you go to the great courses
plus.com/nerd
writer or click the link in the
description.
You can get a 30 day free trial after
that.
Annual memberships are 1490 $9 a month
and monthly memberships are 1990 $9 a
month.
Thanks everybody.
I'll see you next time.